it's important to bring the kids anyway
so they know about the history I think a
lot more could be done we need to have
collective solutions to collective
problems but it's important to remember
like Stokely Carmichael said we were put
in the position that we're in because
we're black or white in this position
because of a collective decision the
collective punishment so we need to have
collective solutions we need to have
reparations we need to have a government
that's actually accountable to the
people which means participatory
democracy I mean to build black power in
order to get what we need
space changeless insane monkeys after
years of fighting for equality and we're
still here that means less to fight for
to make dangerous
nothing has a question kind of really
change